[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsey show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm george campbell ramsay
personality host of the fine print and
entree leadership podcast and i'm joined
today by the wonderful rachel cruz
best-selling author host of the rachel
cruz show all around great person rachel
how are you doing great george this is
our second time hosting together we were
such a fan favorite we're back
the votes are in the votes i wish that
was a true story it was just a luck of
the draw this time but i i do enjoy
hosting with you uh two of our money
personalities together we're like the
avengers
avenging debt i guess and the student
loan crisis take over the world in the
student loan crisis i love it i'm here
for it we should it's a free call this
hour open phones triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number to
call hopefully kelly gets you through
and we can have a conversation about
whatever's on your mind whatever's uh
whatever you're worried about something
maybe you're excited about maybe there's
a decision you're trying to make and you
just need some affirmation from some
friends we are those friends today
that's right that's what i love about
this it's it's everything
around your life right i mean obviously
through the money lens for a lot of
people but money touches every part of
our lives so it adds in
the relationships it adds in the stress
and the anxiety it adds in everything so
it is life i mean in and out day and day
i love it well let's get to it here's
what we're here for sean is on the line
in los angeles sean welcome to the
ramsay show
hi uh thanks for having me absolutely
it's all good
uh
we just bought a my wife just got
married did for um our uh honeymoon and
all that stuff everything is good you
just bought in her car cash um thank you
very much um so we just bought her car
cash um and then we ended up out of
vehicle
so we have about like maybe like 11 000
saved after everything um and then uh
i'm gonna get six thousand back from
from the other one so
i'm wondering uh do we
go like you know do i kind of try to
spend it all on something and try to get
something a little more reliable or do i
nickel and dime at like five thousand
and then throw the rest of it um the
only deal we have is a student loan so
of um trying to tackle that too so i'm
not really sure what we should do
yeah well i mean i don't like the word
only debt yeah it's the only debt i have
how much is this debt the student loan
well it's pretty steep it's like 50 57
000 but we're good good earners and you
know we haven't we had to map out just
something unfortunate happened you know
you know what i mean yeah how urgent is
this car purchase
um
it has to be done yeah i mean uh i mean
yeah i mean we both commute for work so
we got to do it and you have one car
right now
one car yeah okay so you need another
car for the job and you have eleven
thousand dollars saved in cash is that
all of your savings everything liquid
cash you have right now
yeah it was all we had kind of um i
planned on just throwing that straight
at the debt and then and then this came
up so now but we do have i'll get six
thousand back from from everything else
what's everything else
uh my insurance it'll be though you know
big crashes okay so they'll write you a
check for six grand you're saying
yeah okay all right that helps we got
all the details down rachel yeah i mean
sean if i was in your boat because
of the student loan obviously you guys
need a car i mean that is we talk about
your four walls transportation is one of
those so i'm not against obviously you
getting a car uh but no i would not
spend all of this on the car because you
can still get a reliable
used car i mean you can
i mean it's amazing honestly four five
six thousand dollars what that will get
you no it's not gonna be a beautiful car
it's gonna be an older one but you go
get you know a honda civic or a toyota
camry like there are there are cars out
there that their
reputation is to be reliable and again
it may not be the thing you want to
drive for the rest of your life which is
fine but going ahead and getting a car
um as inexpensive as possible so again
i'm talking four five six thousand
dollars and then keeping a thousand for
your emergency fund and then throwing
the rest at this debt so i really would
concentrate on that and the great thing
about
four five six thousand dollar cars is
they really don't go down in value very
quickly so yeah by the time you guys are
out of debt you know in in three more
years you guys can upgrade to an awesome
car and that time is gonna fly so quick
so um i would put as much money towards
the student loan shawn as possible and
sorry i'll add this to sean
you know you and your wife yo hello you
guys have been married what just i mean
really recent you said
oh yeah october yeah they're just coming
october okay
so honestly this is kind of a fun
fun may not be the right word george i
love the word fun so everything feels
fun to me this could be a really
unifying goal for you and your new wife
to to experience something together as a
newlywed couple and any couples but
especially when you're newlyweds to have
something that you guys are sacrificing
and working towards together
um there's something really unifying
about that that you get to experience
early on in marriage so i would almost
look at it like that but hey you know it
sucks that we have all this student loan
debt but man if we attack this together
there is this um
this this bridge between you two that
gets built in such a quicker way when
you have a unified goal yeah and sean
i'll tell you i drive a 2009 honda civic
with body damage so it's exactly what
rachel's saying and i paid six thousand
dollars for it back in 2017.
still drives perfectly today and yeah we
have the money to get a new car but i'm
like that's fine and i kind of like that
it has some body damage you get a little
ding on it you don't care so let this be
a memory that you guys look back on and
let it fuel you to go gosh i hate this
car i wish we had a nicer car let's pay
off this debt asap so that we can get
that nicer car but what happens is
people get a nicer car and they get
comfortable with their student loans
sitting here like a pet and they never
pay them off and so i want you to get
intense
what was that we're hardcore on it we
decided we had already planned on it
it's already i had map out like the next
six months to take care of it we just uh
it's just something came up and i'm like
i don't know if we should you know
totally no i hear you're gonna pay off
the student loan in six months yeah
that's awesome oh that's well hopefully
that's the idea what's your what's your
household income
um together we do like 165 so oh yeah
this thing is definitely gone in six
months or less and guess what you can
then sell that car for probably about
what you paid if the market is what it
is
and you can upgrade uh before the year
is over before 2022 ends
awesome uh thank you very much
absolutely thanks so much for the call
cars are so interesting because there's
like this level of
like a standard of living a level of
luxury this thing that cars have become
it represents something like you know
dave's opener of the show is this you
know the bmw is now the status symbol of
choice and it is i'm like and what i
don't i just laugh at myself sometimes
because i can be that i want a tesla
that's my i'm not a car person but
whenever i see a tesla i'm like man i
want a tesla's so bad
and but like a car gets you from point a
to point b yeah see what i'm saying like
like if you go to like you zoom out
utility
if you just look at the utility of it
and then like you said too the nicer the
car
a little bit more the more stressed you
are the more you're thinking oh gosh i
got to keep it clean if something
happens right it becomes this
this uh it fills your emotional tank
where it's like oh it doesn't need to
right because it's just stuff so there's
cars are just f they're fascinating and
there's a big spectrum especially with
guys i mean guys calling into the show
yeah it's always they want the nice car
and they want to impress the buddies and
they got to have this the premium
features
yeah so i would be curious we could like
take a poll like instagram on the radio
but we can't but i'm like okay for
like the the longing for a new car
especially for a guy
is it do you think george more of the
perception of what it brings
or is it that you just like nice things
and you like to get in to a car and it
smells good it's all new technology like
it's fun
i wonder what percentage it is for most
people out there i think that's a bit of
both but i think if you're an i am
legend scenario and you're the only
person in the world left i don't think
you're that worried about what other
people think about your truck so true i
think part of it is you want to go with
your buddies and go hey dude check out
check out these rooms i just got if i
just got
george if i ever get a tesla i'm going
to i'm going to say george i'm taking
off look at my tesla i will be one of
those people that tells you
i love it well hey folks it's a free
call triple eight eight two five five
two two five i'm george campbell that's
rachel cruz we'll be back with you real
soon
[Music]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
ziprecruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile
they can personally invite you to apply
for the job so if you're ready for an
easier job search check out ziprecruiter
sign up for free right now at
ziprecruiter.com ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell host of the fine print and
entree leadership podcast joined today
by rachel cruz host of the rachel cruz
show all of those you can find on the
ramsey network well i've got a question
for you is it too soon to start talking
about christmas i know thanksgiving's
still a couple weeks away but here's the
deal me and the rest of the ramsey team
are already in a christmas frame of mind
and it's not just the hallmark movies
rachel a big reason for that is that
we're already giving away cash as part
of our christmas cash giveaway we love
being generous around here especially
with dave's money one of my it's my
spiritual gift of mine to give away
dave's money so here we are every year
we celebrate christmas with our ramsay
show listeners with our ramsay christmas
cash giveaway it's become a tradition of
ours and this year we're giving away 500
bucks every single week and a grand
prize of 5 thousand dollars
you can enter every day to increase your
chances of winning just go to
ramseysolutions.com
giveaway to enter and you can go ahead
and get in on the giving too we've got
all kinds of life-changing gifts for
your family and friends and our famous
10 sale that means you can shop over 40
of our best-selling books and envelopes
for just 10 bucks or less get books like
the total money makeover dave's number
one bestseller and rachel's newest book
know yourself and all your money both on
sale for just 10 bucks that's a good
deal this year forget the one-time use
presents and gift a lifetime of hope
shop the 10 sale at ramsaysolutions.com
mike joins us in new york city mike
welcome to the ramsay show
hey guys thanks for taking my call much
appreciated um i have a two-part
question the first part deals with my
pension i am forced by my employer to
put in six percent of my total earnings
towards the pension
and i was curious as to how you guys and
dave think about that six percent as it
contributes to the entire 15 percent
that you recommend for retirement
savings and the second part of my
question deals with my current uh tda my
tax renewal it's a 403 b
and currently i'm putting in uh nine
percent uh of my gross and it's a fixed
guaranteed return of seven percent
that's what i'm guaranteed i guess it
was negotiated through the state
legislator that i'm guaranteed to do
seven percent i was told that this is
very rare and it's a great deal but i've
also been told by you guys that
opening up a roth ira is a really good
choice so i'm debating about moving my
finances from my 403 b
into a roth ira
maxing that out six grand five grand or
six grand a year i forgot what the max
contribution is and then whatever i have
left over putting that leftover towards
the 403b annuity uh with a guaranteed
fixed seven percent i just want to know
what you guys think about that second
question as well okay cool so let's
start with the first question
the mandatory six percent contribution
is that coming from your own salary this
is not something that the employer is
contributing on their part
yeah it's from my own salary comes right
on my paycheck i have no choice in the
matter so they're just forcing your
first six percent out of the 15
essentially
exactly because i'm part of the uh you
know new york city and part of the state
the pension contribution is is mandatory
okay
yeah i mean i don't see anything wrong
with counting that as part of your 15
since it's coming out of your paycheck
yes yeah so yep that'll be that will be
included in the 15. um and then whatever
is left of that it's looking like you
said i got the 403b what percentage are
you putting in the b
so i'm putting in nine percent so if i
do the six percent for the pen and then
another nine yeah i mean
right yes well
my knee-jerk reaction alway i just love
the roth ira i mean it is it is tried
and true and it grows tax-free and
usually you can get more i mean another
they're guaranteeing seven percent
but with the roth my husband i even just
looked at our stuff
the rate of return yeah it's just you
can get more
even just in the market and so that's
where i tend to lean
um mike to go ahead like you said that
your knee jerk reaction i i would
i would do that i would do as much as i
can in that roth ira but then whatever
is left after you do that that's six
thousand five six thousand dollars when
you max out that roth if there is
anything left i think you i think you
just walked us through it i'm like
that's exactly right you i would put the
rest in that 403 b
yeah i guess i'm calling just to confirm
i'm doing the steps correctly and i
think i am i guess my only concern was
what is some you know if you look at the
s p 500 over the last 30 years i think
it's what an average rate of return of
around eight eight and a half which is
obviously higher than seven percent the
only great thing about the 10 is that
it's guaranteed it's set by the state
legislator i have literally zero risk of
loss all at all so that's why it's like
oh that's pretty unique and unheard of
so that's why i was questioning what
percentage
should i only put one or two percent
towards that uh fixed rate of return
then dump the rest into the roth ira and
you guys are saying yes it is in fact
worth it yeah i think it is because i
think you're gonna get i think you're
gonna average out more than seven
percent over this how old are you mike
i'm 37. okay so yeah i mean you you
still have you've got plenty you've got
a few decades and so i would because
again i think that um while the market
sure goes up and down
um it's it it's done great and so i
don't know another piece of this rachel
is the control factor in the roth ira
you're going to have control of what
funds are invested i don't know mike how
much control you have over the options
in this 403 b
piece if they're guaranteeing that seven
percent i don't know how they're
guaranteeing that or if they have full
control what's the situation there
these so great questions from what i
understand the the fixed guarantee
return 10 that was negotiated through my
union and
collective bargaining through the state
legislature so seven percent is locked
in place now that is an option for me in
addition to that i also have options of
playing around with the market doing uh
equity diversity funds i can i can uh
sort of you know spread my
uh contributions however i want but
currently i'm putting it all in the
bucket of fixed return
um does that make sense got it yeah yeah
yeah and what i would do too is you can
bounce this off of one of our
smartvestor pros in your area financial
advisor who can just go hey this is
what's going to make the most sense for
your age for where what your situation
is and your goals they can walk through
all the nitty-gritty the nerdy numbers
with you to help you make that decision
but if i'm you i'm going to the roth ira
whatever's left over it's not a bad plan
to uh to throw some money in that as
well especially with the guaranteed um
rate of return there so thanks for the
question appreciate that
matt joins us next in houston texas matt
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you for having me guys how are
y'all doing today doing great how can we
help awesome so my wife and i are new uh
to the baby steps we're currently on
baby step two
um trying to pay off some of our debts
and um before we got on board with the
whole program
i had invested during the
pandemic when the market crashed i
invested into some stocks which i'm
learning now that it's not the best
option to have
so what we're trying to figure out is if
it would make sense to go ahead and pull
out our current investments um obviously
take out what
what would be tax for capital gains and
put that aside
for the end of the year
but then utilize the
the other funds to pay off
some of our debt i'm just wondering if
that's a good idea or what you guys
would suggest we do with that yeah i
like this plan so far how much debt do
you have
so we currently have about
five thousand dollars in debt fifty of
that being student loans uh the other
two are car loans okay and what uh
what's how much is in this investment
uh total and the investment is around
twenty one thousand okay so we're not
going to knock out the debt completely
even by cashing these hours but it'll
help kick-start this process for you
right right
yeah yeah that's the thought process at
least to at least get that going i mean
we also have
around 11 000 in savings and that's kind
of like
that's our limit right now as my wife
just gets a little weary when the bank
drops a little bit um especially with my
with my job i'm prone to injuries
because i teach tennis and so like right
now i'm doing some injury pains and a
hernia and so that extra money she
she
doesn't want to go below that just in
case something happens but um again you
know any guidance on on that situation
would be would be helpful for us as well
yeah well your first um question matt i
would anything that is not retirement i
would cash out and throw at the debt
because
you're going to be able to go and invest
double twice three times as more when
you have no payments like when you guys
are completely debt-free and you have an
emergency fund
suddenly you're gonna feel your income
be able to be like oh my gosh this is
amazing and then you can you guys have
time to go and invest more into things
like retirement and that security gland
is flaring up over here but if i'm you
guys i'm going down to that 1 000 that's
gonna give you 31 total throw at the
debt and the sooner you get rid of this
debt that's when you have true security
true financial peace so i think you guys
have the hard conversation about using
this money in savings to kick start this
debt and really start to paint the
picture of what you want that future to
look like
rooting for you guys this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
i'm george campbell next to me is rachel
cruz and this is the ramsay show it's a
free call triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's have a
conversation about your life and your
money what's on your mind let us know
let's have a little fun friday
conversation about it agnes decided to
join us in new york city agnes welcome
to the ramsay show
hi thanks so much for taking my call
absolutely my question is
my question is that my husband and i are
finishing baby step three so we're
getting ready for
investing and we're starting to think
about it
yay but we don't know anything about
investing at least not much
and i was wondering if um if a smart
investor probe would be helpful in um
you know when we start to invest in a
company 401k or that's something that
you know
you know
being that it's not there
we're not investing with the smart
investor pro would they still help with
that
yeah absolutely yeah i in fact have a
smart vester pro and i show them what's
going on in my company ramsey 401k and
every year i'll just go hey does this
still make sense to you all the you know
allocated across these funds and it's it
takes the pressure off of me to go oh
okay good i'm doing the right thing i
shouldn't be doing anything differently
so absolutely they have a heart of a
teacher and they'll educate you from
start to finish that's why they're there
they're not there to sell you on
products they're there to help you
understand where you're putting your
money yeah and hopefully you know for
you guys um
you you'll have more to invest than just
the 401k because you'll take that match
but then maybe you'll open up a roth ira
like we talked about in the last segment
there there are other retirement options
out there that they can even help show
you and and i'll say this you know i
remember when i had my husband and i we
got married uh we 12 years ago which is
so crazy and after we got married
we sat down with the smartmaster pro
that was here in nashville and and even
being dave ramsey's daughter let me just
say i had so many questions i didn't
quite even understand some of it and i
kind of felt stupid at first
asking some of the questions i was like
these are probably dumb questions that
are like super elementary and i should
know this but the more i asked and the
more he started explaining
i was like okay there's just that
there's a level of knowledge you're
gonna want when you're putting your
money into something so don't be afraid
to ask questions honestly you may you
may you may feel stupid or like i should
know this i'm an adult you know i pay
taxes like i feel like i should know
these things uh and you me and you don't
i mean or you may not like i in things
like insurance i laughed about taxes but
seriously taxes investing
it's these niche parts of our financial
picture
that people that work in these
industries hopefully the ones that you
know or the ones that we recommend
are kind people they're going to help
you
and they're there to teach you like
george said and these people eat and
breathe this stuff they do it day in and
day out they meet with all types of
people
all income level i mean they see it all
so i don't want you to feel inadequate
at all when you guys go sit down for the
first time ask as many questions i want
you
to be a be able to understand what
you're putting your money into so when
you leave that office that you could
explain it to someone else right like
that you know it so well um so
absolutely i would have a financial
advisor in my corner and do my first
degree first i understand and do we
first go to the the
other financial advisor or do we first
try to open it up with the company the
401k
well it'll probably be through it'll be
through your company but they're going
to be able to to guide you in it like
what george is saying and then other
things that you may decide to put your
money in they're going to be able to
help you in that so you can open up the
401k and then they can help you select
what funds inside of that 401k you're
putting your money into and so that's
what's going to help obviously we have a
lot of resources at ramseysolutions.com
to help teach you how what the ramsey
way is across four different types of
growth stock mutual funds and we've got
a new book coming out from dave baby
steps millionaires where he really
unpacks his own investing strategy and i
love that dave does exactly what he
tells other people to do he's not out
here jumping on single stocks and
telling everyone else to go into mutual
funds so
we really try to practice what we preach
around here and those smartvestor pros
they're aligned with the ramsey
principles and they're going to treat
you right so absolutely reach out and
just get some information and get some
guidance from them
even if it's for your company 401k and
maybe down the line like rachel said you
work with them on another project like
we did that when we were saving up for
our down payment oh yeah we invested for
the long term and we worked with our
smart mr pro absolutely agnes way to go
baby step four here we come feels good
yeah that's awesome thanks for the call
josh joins us next in seattle washington
josh welcome to the ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call george and
rachel yeah i'm a small business owner
out here and we've built this business
over 10 years and done fine but the last
couple years we've just gone gangbusters
made more money than we've ever made and
uh we've through that my wife and i have
accumulated a good stockpile of cash
just in regular savings accounts
and we're looking to build a house in
the next couple of years so for now i've
just left that in savings accounts it's
been piling up and we're getting a half
a percent of interest which is the very
highest rate we can find around my
question is should i be doing something
else that money just feels wrong
especially with all the talk of
inflation the reality of inflation i'm
not worried about hyperinflation but
there's a reality right now especially
in the building cost world
or should we just sit on that uh you
know depending on when we're going to
build the house probably starting as
soon as next spring and just sit on it
and wait um
what you think we should do
yeah it's a great question i'm just
curious josh what do you guys do for a
living just what's what's going crazy
what kind of business
sure yeah we're in the gun and ammo
business awesome there you go that has
gone crazy
very cool
um yeah so i i'll say
if you guys know you're gonna be
building in the next
three years or less four years or less i
would just keep it where it is josh
which i know hurts my husband and i we
did the same thing we had saved and it
we we had saved um
for longer than even that and kept it
just in like a money market and we look
back and winston was like i guess that
was the right decision you know we still
talk about it because it was over a
longer period of time um but especially
if you go if especially if it's three
years or less our rule of thumb at
ramsay's really five years or less um
and so in this case anywhere from three
to five years if you know you're gonna
be building in that time i would just
keep it where it is even though i get it
like you're not making a ton back i know
but um
it's kind of the safest route it's just
the money that you have because if
something dips if something happens and
you guys want to go and build and you
don't have the time to let it regain
where it was
then that kind of sucks yeah when you
have that tight time horizon of we want
to build at this date that's where i
start to get real nervous about putting
it in the market for a short period of
time josh how much money is this
uh in our personal savings accounts
about 500 550 000 and then we're a
little heavy on the business right now
another 250 thousand retained earnings
in the business which is a lot more than
we normally keep there so
are you guys are you guys investing
though john like or josh for um like
retirement and all of that like are you
are you doing other stuff are you just
really focusing on yeah
we've been doing
15 of our of our take-home pay at raises
a good point i guess we haven't we just
continued to do that off our base salary
that we pay ourselves i've not done that
out of this excess so perhaps that is a
portion of it that we should take and
then set aside for long-term investing
this excess we've just piled up you know
in in cash and along the way paid
another 400 000 for a piece of land that
we'll build on so that's you know debt
free and yeah ready to build but yeah
that's all i was gonna say is that you
can should we
use that no i would use what you have to
to do is put as much away to the house
as possible when you guys start building
for sure
should we take 15 of that and invest it
is that considered part of our 15 part
of our income on which we should be
doing investing no i wouldn't if you
guys already are investing on just the
income you said you're doing it on the
take-home pay though right the investing
well we're doing it on our on our base
salary so we've paid ourselves for years
uh we take 15 of that you know out of
our regular you know 130 000 bucks a
year or whatever and and invest on that
out of all this excess we've done zero
investing no i think that's fine uh
because again you're you're saving this
money for the house to build so that's
what this is a lot of different goal
here how much uh house are we talking
ideally for you guys uh pro
probably the bill probably cost
somewhere within eight nine hundred
thousand okay i mean i you guys are so
close to being able to pay cash for
something like this you just kept saving
up with this business crushing it like
it is and you waited two years
i mean that could be a really cool
stretch goal for you guys
yeah you know and i think if we sell our
current house that we're in it'll
definitely be able to cash flow and
that's another question in the back of
our mind is do we keep that as a rental
or do we sell the current place and
and you know just cash flow the whole
build so yeah if you're able to cash for
the whole build i would keep it it's
pretty bad for a rental yeah i would if
you got a paid for property and yeah i
mean that's that's pretty cool man you
guys have done right now congrats josh i
love hearing stories like that right
awesome warms my heart
i see people go yeah we got like 800 000
in cash and we're crushing it i mean
this is this is what we like to hear so
thank you so much for the call of josh
way to go
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined by rachel cruz
today
and it's a free call triple eight eight
two five five two two five call us up
we'll talk about your life and your
money michael joins us in phoenix
michael welcome to the ramsay show
yes hi george rachel thank you for
taking my call i hope you guys are
better than you deserve we are for sure
how are you doing
well pretty good pretty good um so a
couple questions well one major uh
a little bit of background
just became homeless back in september
um gives you some unforeseen
circumstances sorry um
but i'm a single dad two kids um trying
to uh
uh build back better if you will
and
i have a great job
but
don't know where to don't know where to
start really i
got my emergency fund in place
got into a cheaper car got into a
cheaper apartment
and just really trying to
take control of my finances so my
finances aren't taking control of me
anymore yeah
well it sounds like you're you're doing
a lot better than you were
not long ago so you're in an apartment
now you've got somewhere safe to stay
and the kids are safe
yep absolutely and you've got the job
what's your income
uh
don't know the uh annual but at 26 an
hour
i'm a drunk driver truck driving 26 an
hour that's great
and uh are is child care a part of the
equation here
they're negative okay
good good and you have debt
uh i don't know how you would label
consumer debt but creditor debt
okay how much debt is owed currently
uh student loans car
a couple of hospital bills
right around 30.
30 000.
okay and you've got an emergency fund in
place how much is in there
uh about 1200
1200 bucks so you're right you've got
that baby step one going that starter
emergency fund and you have a reliable
car and you've got a place to stay and
you can afford the the rent there
correct okay
well you're honestly i'm i'm impressed
it sounds like you've been through
a whole lot in the past i don't know a
few months how recent is all of this
uh september
wow
man you are resilient yeah michael
you've done you've done an amazing job
do you know that right
well it's my kids i learn from my kids i
work for my kids i love my kids yeah
well it's a good why in there because
what you've been through is
i mean it's hard it's really hard and
especially if you're the
sole provider of that i know the weight
that that
feels and that responsibility that you
feel and i feel like the thing that
sucks about money is that you know your
past decisions they do follow you you
know you're having to face these things
that you're like man
i hate it but um
but you you have not let it completely
just overtake you or define you i mean
you really have i hear it in your voice
of i'm gonna i'm gonna do something
different because what i did didn't work
and so i'm willing to change and do the
hard work
to dig myself out of this and i just
think that's like it's just really
impressive and really brave to make big
changes like this in your life michael
so i just i want to encourage you in
that
um and that this that this debt it is um
is it all in collections because you
were talking about creditors
incorrect yeah it's all online questions
okay
well
one positive note in some of that maybe
not as much the student loans but the
other stuff there are chances that you
can negotiate with them when it gets to
this point
um and and once you get some money um
let's just use like one of them for an
example what how much would you say is
on the car for instance
uh 16
16 000 okay so you know working to
to get some cash and sometimes they will
settle with you um
and to say hey it's been x amount of
time and here's what i have what's the
best thing you can do
um for me what's the best deal you know
you can give me i mean there's always
that strategy as well that um is a
possibility not that it's all in
collections but
um if that doesn't work then obviously
kind of just chipping away at this and
it'll be it'll be a marathon you know
it's not gonna happen happen
overnight like we say around here but
uh getting those quick wins of paying
off that smallest one is going to be um
it's going to be exciting what is your
smallest step michael
uh about a thousand okay okay awesome
well you got 1200
in the bank so you know you can do it
you know you can work and save that um
so that'll feel that'll feel real good
when you when you hit that first one out
yeah so if you're following the baby
steps we talk about the four walls and
it sounds like you've got those covered
that's food utilities shelter
transportation once we have that covered
you can move on to that starter
emergency fund which you have and then
next up we're going to list those debts
from smallest to largest depending on
what's going on with the creditors and
like rachel said the older the debt has
been in collections the better chance
you have of settling and so if i'm you
right now i'm gonna work my tail off
maybe that means taking a second job
doing anything to increase income and
cut down expenses to create that margin
so that we can save up you know eight
thousand dollars and go to that car loan
and say hey i've got eight are you
willing to take that today and be done
with this and a lot of the times they'll
say we'd rather have some of the money
than none of it yeah and they'll take
that and that can be knocked out in the
medical bills especially a lot of those
can be negotiated down
especially with hardship and income so
do your research and be proactive
communicating with the creditors uh you
know call them once a week give them
updates i want you to bother them more
than they bother you uh
they're gonna want you off their back
instead and so you've done an incredible
job um obviously i want this debt out of
your life as soon as possible so that
you can really start to create that new
financial future for you and your kids
how old are the kids
14 and 12. wow awesome that's awesome
and are they are they in school what's
their situation yeah
school full-time okay awesome
that's good that frees you up to be able
to to work are you
back home every night with this trucking
gig
oh yeah yeah i'm local okay that's great
news well you know the good news is the
trucking industry is in high demand and
so you might even look into what other
jobs are out there can i increase this
income ca is there overtime i know that
can be difficult in the trucking
industry with um regulation but just
doing whatever you can for the next you
know maybe it's two years to knock out
this debt especially if you can settle
some of it it could be shorter than that
and once you're through with that you
get that fully funded emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses and then
you can rest easy at night and start
investing for your future how old are
you
36 36 dude you got your whole life ahead
of you
you've got a whole new life to start a
new legacy to build with these kids
and uh i mean you know what to do and i
i think you're going to do it you're a
resilient guy nothing's going to stop
you at this point from where you were to
where you are today and where you're
going to be
that's right
and my kids have a
full life ahead of them and i want
theirs to be better than me
and it will michael i mean honestly
financially yep i mean you're you're
literally making doing the steps right
now
to what we say around here all the time
is changing your family tree and that's
exactly exactly what you've been doing
do you feel more hopeful today than
than even
three weeks ago like as you start really
making progress and you save and and
you're feeling kind of the traction of
this working how how does
i was able to pay off a creditor last
week and it felt amazing amazing it's
discouraging when i can't do it every
week but
it you know it gives me hope yeah
and that's awesome well you keep taking
one day at a time keep busting your butt
for this family clearly that's your why
so let that y fuel you along this
journey and start to dream of what that
future looks like and what it looks like
to maybe being a home one day or be
doing the job you really want to do and
the kids going to college and just start
to dream about that future and that's
going to keep you going every day that's
what you need right now is that daily
motivation
listen to this show for motivation get a
community around you if you don't have
any right now some friends who can cheer
you on along the way some family that's
really going to help you get through
this journey
no thank you absolutely michael thank
you so much for the call we are cheering
you on my friend
yes what a good dad i know i'm just
impressed by this guy and it sounds hard
like the road he just explained i'm like
oh that i mean it's hard yeah and yet
choosing to say okay i'm i'm gonna do
this i'm gonna i'm gonna figure this out
get another job
find an apartment i mean all of it
that's that's so courageous to me
because
there's a lot of you know and i get it
but there's some it's just like i don't
even know what to do they're stuck and
they can't move it's almost like they're
paralyzed by fear but he didn't really
know really digging in and said okay i'm
going to do something different and i'm
going to change what i've been doing
which is uncomfortable in the first
place let alone
his life situation so i think it's
amazing call us up or come visit us to
do your debt-free screening that's right
from homeless to debt-free that's a cool
story that's inspiring man absolutely
fun hour rachel thank you so much big
thanks to james childs our producer
kelly daniels our phone screener and you
america we appreciate you listening in
we'll be back with you before you know
it until then spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously this
is the rambly show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
screen live on the show make sure you
visit thermzyshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsey show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm ramsay personality george
campbell join this hour by rachel cruz
national number one best-selling author
host of the rachel cruz show you name it
she's it she's got it all folks and i'm
excited to be co-hosting with her today
taking your questions about life and
money it's a free call triple eight
eight two five five two two five if
you're a gen z or millennial that's a
phone number and if you pick up your
phone there's a phone app you can
actually dial those numbers and it
connects you with a real person don't
throw the millennials
i'm a millennial i'm the same way now
we can we can throw it here's the thing
rachel i'm the first one to not want to
make a phone call i'd much rather text
yes i know but to make the show
interesting we have to hear you and so i
just want to encourage people out there
who may not make a lot of phone calls to
make it the day they do so you know
speaking of phone calls can i tell you
something i think we're going to do
george this is so off topic we just need
to get to the calls
speaking of phones
we're going back to a landline
really at the crew's household we're
going to get a landline tell me the
reasoning behind this
for our girls
they love talking on the phone but they
always take our phones and i'm like
wouldn't it be great for them and like
obviously grandparents would just have
their number
but that they could call
like my parents or winston's parents
it's a real actual call and it's a phone
and they and they got or they or how
sweet would it be for someone to call
the landline and the and the girls feels
like we're living in mr rogers
neighborhood i love this isn't that
great doesn't it just kind of take you
back to just so we bought on amazon like
like felt like actual phones very
impressive anyways i thought winston was
like a doomsday prepper and if the
satellites go
down i'm the conspiracy theorist you're
here for that that's okay secret reason
i can't wait till the phone rings at
home and um one of your girls answers
and it's like would you like to
re-extend your warranty for your
whatever i know
or your student loan is in deferment
like some spam i'm here for it though
let me know how that goes okay so
here's get it landline let's just go
back to the day the good old days it's
gonna it's gonna be vintage soon and
cool just like the 90s clothing has been
so did you ever have your own phone line
100
okay instead of the party line yeah
where you could pick up yeah yeah not
the party line but you had like euro
like we had a kids line growing up oh no
no i wasn't that fancy and our um should
i do our recording or so off topic right
now james is about to shut are you ready
james are you ready he's invested in
this though go for it should we do this
i'm sorry america
i can't this is a treat
okay we did a wrap
please do this
this is rachel denise's line you know
what to do leave a message get back to
you
wow there you go folks you didn't know
you wanted to hear that but you got it
and that is a friday treat you're
welcome thank you so much for that
rachel that is that was broadcast live
on national radio yeah i want to remind
you i know i mean did you have to like
sing christmas songs on your recorder
like no one made me yeah apparently it's
a different time in the ramsay household
wow all right so behind the scenes for
you folks
terrible back to the back to the phones
that matter
tommy's on the line in phoenix arizona
tommy i apologize and we're excited to
talk to you how you doing
hey no no worries i'm doing well thank
you for taking my call guys did you
expect to hear a rap from rachel cruz
right before you talk to us
i didn't but to add to the conversation
i'm actually a millennial so
yeah
tommy don't you want a landline back in
your life doesn't that just feel better
i'd be down i used to talk to the
operators all the time when i was
younger my mom would be like tell me
give me the phone tommy
i love this guy well how can we help 69
i mean all of it that's great
yeah yeah so my wife and i are somewhat
newly married two and a half years in
and um she's studying to actually become
a doctor or a pa so she's kind of in
that
waiting season right now so um i was
just curious we're on baby step 3b and i
was curious if i should just be throwing
100 of that right towards you know
that fund for her schooling or if uh we
should be investing uh through my
company's uh retirement plan 401k plan a
little background we have about 75 000
in savings 20 of that being our six
month emergency fund and so that leaves
us with between 55 to 65 000 uh
towards school right now cool how much
is school going to cost
yeah so school depending upon if she
wants to go the pa route or the doctor
route in state uh it will be about 60
000 for
uh for the three years uh for pa or a
160 000 for in-state doctorate program
okay and that's 60 per year for three
years
no sir so it's not only the 35 per year
it's awesome that's very reasonable
yeah it is i think most of the time with
doctors and pas they just think they're
forced to take the loan route so they
put in all of their spendings like
housing food expenses and that's why
they get so uh
this is just in-state tuition that's
awesome
well what's great about it too is she's
gonna have to
when will she have to make the decision
for the 160 thousand dollar route when
will that happen
um probably within the next couple
months right now because of coveting
stuff she hasn't been been able to
really get like any little to any
shadowing hours and that's really uh
pivotal for for um uh doctorate school
for medical school so um right now it's
kind of looking like she might go the pa
route because she has more experiences
higher chances were getting uh uh
approved essentially or accepted um but
yeah that within the next couple months
i'd say lord willing that's awesome well
i mean on that route obviously you guys
have the cash to and and you don't to
pay at all up front obviously right
you're gonna be paying
as she goes which is great which means
you're gonna be able to still continue
to save because you have this money set
aside basically for her tuition and
you'll still continue to be able to save
and then
um ideally you know if she goes the
other route knowing that okay we're
gonna have to save on the side
uh and work harder and be more focused
to continue to still cash flow her if
she chooses that 160 000 route um but
the 65 000 paid for route sounds
and here's the thing with pa if she goes
the pa route she can always go the
doctor route later correct
uh that's kind of no not really you'd
have to do everything over again all
over
you'd have to go back to from what i
understand you'd have to go back to
medical school and then do the three
four years of residency on top so it's
not really uh
it's they really try to differentiate
the difference between pa and doctorate
yeah and keep them separate so that way
that there's the two distinct routes and
so i guess for respecting doctors and
the work they put into it and things
like that sure well so i would say on
the money side though tommy if yes i
would
i would continue to invest
um
yeah for retirement if she goes the 65
000 out because you'll have it basically
paid for it's there and you have your
and you'll still have your your
emergency funds uh in place
so yeah that now if she goes the other
route then i would pause the investing
and then just keep saving up cash and
cash flow her through it but for her i
would ask her too
i mean that's a hundred thousand dollar
difference i'm kind of just making these
numbers seem like they're not that big
of a difference that's a that's a big
difference but and if the outcome yeah
and if the outcome is the same for her
if she's getting what she wants out of
her career
out of both then it's the same i mean
obviously i would i would pick the pa
route just to be able to cash flow it
and she could jump into it all of it uh
but but if it's something that she's
passionate about the the other routes
then she can still do that you always
have to pause a lot and save a lot to
make sure your cash flowing up yeah and
the upside of the income from the doctor
versus pa look into that and find out
what the difference is and we want to
make sure there's going to be a good roi
on this regardless but cash flow it
avoids student loan debt you guys are
doing so great you're following the
steps super proud of you guys rockstar
millennials look at that rachel they're
out there you can find them
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
i'm george campbell my co-host today is
rachel cruz this is the ramsay show if
you aren't strapped with student loan
payments odds are you know someone who
is
millions of people are putting their
lives on hold they can't buy a house or
have kids because they're stuck or even
worse they're waiting and waiting and
waiting for the government to save them
with student loan forgiveness what a
joke
our team produced a brand new
documentary called borrowed future and
it is out now it uncovers the dark side
of the student loan industry and exposes
how the system is built to work against
you you'll see dave ramsey weigh in on
the epic failure otherwise known as the
student loan program along with featured
interviews from industry insiders and
thought leaders like seth godin seth
fraughtman and dr john deloney we're
coming at this hard folks we're taking
big swings at the student loan problem
with the goal to arm parents and
students across the country with the
truth here's the truth you do not have
to take out loans to get a college
education you can graduate debt-free and
avoid the predatory student loan
industry borrowed future is available to
watch now you can find it on apple tv
amazon prime video google play or just
go to borrowed future dot com
rachel i love that call we took before
the break about student loans and
his wife's going to go to med school
debt-free i know isn't that great you
don't hear that very often and it's
because they had a plan and they they
had a wise choice when it came to what
college she's going in state and that
whole program 60 grand for pa yes and
she's doing it and i and he's exactly
right that
you know when you just even entertain
the idea of debt and you think okay well
i mean we gotta it's got we have to have
debt and you and you go down that
mindset that trail
then you're not nickel and diming
everything you're you're adding stuff
here and there and oh here here here do
what i'm saying like you don't feel the
urgency to get it as low as possible and
that's on anything even a car right if
you think oh i'm gonna have to get a car
law and you're like oh yeah i'll do that
upgrade here yeah it's 40 versus 50.
yeah you don't feel it um but when you
pay cash that's one of the that's one of
the beauties about it is that you end up
spending less
but also it's because you're working so
hard to get the price down because
you're like no this is my hard-earned
money and you feel it and i wonder if
there's data on this but people who pay
cash for school i wonder if they're more
invested if they're studying like that
if they're trying to ace the test
because you paid good money for that or
the graduation rates higher yeah yeah i
wonder i i would guess that it's higher
i'm sure there's that cash and i bet
there's stuff out there for sure but i'm
proud of them i'm proud of people going
you know what their student loans aren't
the only path and we're going to forge
our own path over here and we're going
to do it with cash and uh they're going
to do it
and here's what's like when i'm sitting
the seat especially and i'm talking to
people like man it can be frustrating
because
we know it's possible
we know it's possible choosing a school
you can afford even going to a community
college scholarships and grants work
like all of these this formula is it
easy no it's not easy
but it is possible and then when we you
know talk to people that do have debt
their largest amount of debt always is
the student loan and it's like oh man i
did a instagram post of some shoes that
i bought that it was like my buyer's
remorse is what i say like my one of my
spending regrets in life um
and they
and some people and so i asked people
what's your biggest spending regret and
so many it was student loans because
it's like years later it's a degree
they're not using
um or they could have gone to a
different school and gotten it half you
know the price of what they pay anyways
i just thought that was fascinating i
wasn't thinking when i thought spending
time with you think about it purchase
you don't think about student loans yeah
yeah i was expecting like a thing and so
but hearing so many
student loan answers in there of the
regret and i'm like yeah i mean it is
it's a hard one so the documentary bard
feature it's it's amazing yeah go watch
it if you haven't it's 88 minutes it's a
great weekend watch and if you've got
kids oh my goodness it's a great thing
to watch with them because it sparks
conversations what i found after talking
with so many teens is that parents
aren't having the conversations and so
they're wandering into college when
they're 17 18 going my parents never
really talked about it and they just
said we'll figure it out next thing you
know they co-signed loans or took out
the parent plus loans or let the
students go off and take out 200 grand
on their own and it all comes down to
communication expectations where are we
at financially how much can we
contribute and a lot of it stems from
shame from the parents too yeah sure we
can't pay for college so we don't even
want to talk about it right right but
that's what i even love about this
message of getting under like the
underbelly of this whole industry
because like you're saying these are 18
year olds making decisions so there is
there's a part of me that i mean and
that ramsay i'm like we want to fight
for those 18 year olds it's not fair for
them to walk in to an office and they
have no clue what they're doing because
no adult has talked them through it and
someone says sign and they sign because
they don't really know i mean they're 18
years old like isn't it that your
frontal uh like your brain
cortex isn't even fully developed like
25 or something and i'm like oh you know
they're making these decisions that
follow them for the rest of their life
so parents i mean george i think that's
great i think it's a great encouragement
for parents to dig in and have the
conversation yes talk about it go check
it out borrowedfuture.com
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five alexandra
joins us from chicago illinois alexandra
welcome to the ramsay show
hi george hi hi rachel how are you doing
great how can we help
um i'm 32 years old i'm in baby step
number two
for the first time in my life i feel
like i have you know some control
um 2020 really kicked me into gear to
start in my debt
i started with 124 now i'm at 81 000.
way to go congratulations
thank you
i went from making less than 20 thousand
a year to now making over 50.
great um but i'm having
a little bit of guilt
about a little bit quite a bit actually
like this morning i'm crying about it
um i'm having guilt
with
kevin um i have two brothers who live in
mexico
and they are
way under the poverty line
and i feel that
now i'm at a place where i can actually
help them
but everything that i'm doing in my
budget and all the extra money that is
going towards my my
debt i feel like i should be helping
them
i mean you have you have a beautiful
heart i mean i can just hear over the
phone your um
your longing and compassion for brothers
that you love and knowing that how their
their their living conditions and living
below the poverty line it's it's it
hurts you right i can i can
i can feel that um
um
i i have two thoughts around and george
obviously i want to hear yours but
my first is that we always encourage
giving no matter even on baby step two
we want you to be giving and really 10
is like
our recommended percentage
um because the element of giving it we
want that even from the beginning
because it makes it
that much easier to continue to give as
you start to build wealth so
so that giving portion you can choose
where to give that and so you know for
uh people that are part of a local
church for instance we say hey that can
be your tithe you can give that to your
local church or if someone is not um
have a spiritual walk it could be to a
non-profit or something so alexandria i
mean you could say hey this ten percent
i'm gonna give
to my brothers to help them right now um
in this season i would not be mad at
that it's not like you're enabling some
bad behavior right i mean there's a
they're just a totally different
situation in mexico and so
um you could choose to do that and then
still focus on your debt snowball
because my my other point that i want
you to hear is once you pay this off
even though it's it's going to be a
little bit of a journey for you still
you you've you've knocked out for what
forty thousand forty three thousand
already which is amazing
um and so you're going to be able to
beat debt-free sooner than you can even
imagine and when you don't have those
payments and you have that emergency
fund you're going to be able to do so
much more giving which is even more
exciting and it's easier to give because
you have the margin when you don't have
the debt
so i do want you to still be intense
with it because because ultimately it
gives you not just you freedom
but it gives you the ability to help
others in that sense when you don't have
the payments so
um so if you want to be giving a little
bit to them right now while you're out
of debt of that giving portion of your
budget i i i don't see anything wrong
with that um because you you are helping
someone that's beautifully said and one
thing i would add is you probably can't
give them enough money to to get them
out of the situation that's great and so
i don't want you to feel like you have
the burden to fix their life but what
you can do is support them in figuring
out what it looks like to get them back
on their feet and that may not be
monetary that might be finding them an
opportunity um from where where you sit
in chicago and going hey let's find you
a job where you're able to afford your
bills and get out of this poverty
situation and that may not mean the 50
to 100 bucks that you might be sending
them every month but you've got a
beautiful heart and we're cheering you
on on your debt-free journey and
definitely hopeful that your brothers
can get out of this situation thank you
so much for that call
sweet stuff rachel good stuff there this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the fine print and entree
leadership podcast joined today by
rachel cruz host of the rachel cruz show
rachel in the first hour we took a call
from a gentleman wondering if he should
buy a car how much car he should be
buying
uh with some other goals he had going on
and you decided to do a little poll on
your instagram
what was going on with that poll
well we were talking about you know how
cars have become the status symbol right
that's what dave always says in the
opening of the show
um
and and how a car really is supposed to
just get you from point a to point b but
yet it's become
this luxury item in our world that
people love so
i just asked the question
i asked people to be honest i don't know
if they're very honest george that's a
good start yeah yeah at least asking for
honesty i did so i asked
why do you want a nice car
because of what other people think or
you just like nice stuff
and the winner which i guess i'm not
shocked is i know i gotta get these up
perfect okay
was 93
like nice stuff okay seven percent
say
because of what people think wow i i
appreciate that the seven percent's
honesty saying i'm just doing it for
other people i just think it's more
right it's gotta be i think the numbers
or there was a third 66 people
said because of what other people think
836 said wow
uh because they like nice stuff again
that was just in the last hour if there
was an option c do you think most people
would select that of a little bit about
a little bit of both i like nice stuff i
mean that would be i mean yeah i don't
want to be ridiculed think about my
tesla
eighty percent is for me because i just
genuinely 80 20. eighty percent i like
nice stuff
like oh yeah tesla people are probably
oh that's a cool tesla if you get a
tesla you know if you rolled up to
ramsey solutions in that tesla i'd be
like
rachel this is a dope car like it would
i would be very impressed i'd want to
ride right and am i lying to say hey
that i'm like it feels good right but
that being your leader your leading
motivator in life when it comes to money
is terrible so that's like where it gets
super unhealthy it'll set you up for
failure yeah yeah and i always ask the
question if nobody sees the purchase do
you still want it and i've done that
with my tesla dreaming and yeah i do
like it like literally no one ever saw i
want to sit and drive an electric car so
bad yeah it's fun
what's your dream car nobody's even if
nobody saw it like that you just
genuinely were like oh that would be fun
i'm going tesla too because i'm a giant
nerd and i like the tech
i just like the technology i don't need
the revving engine like dave does dave's
like i don't hear
that's not a car that's a computer
listen if i never had to do an oil
change again
praise jesus god we just spent so car ah
man why are we getting on the scene
we had car repairs uh this month
this month and the oil pan which i don't
even know that's a thing had to be
replaced and that's like what is
supposed to be replacing cars that have
like 200 000 miles now mine's up in like
90 000. yeah
but yeah you got like the it was
terrible and then they had to fly it in
from a you know another country and then
it gets stuck on some ship
and they can't come to port and all of
it anyways the car was in the shop
forever and i was just angry i was like
i hate core stuff one more reason to get
the tesla all right
amen well hey open phones this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we'll talk about what you wanna
talk about and if that's cars that's
great but we've got esmerelda on the
line in stockton california and we'll
see what her question is esmerelda
welcome to the ramsay show
hi guys thank you for taking my call
sure speak directly into your phone it
sounds a little noisy
so i just had a quick question um
i am about to which not careers but jobs
um
i'm currently work as a correctional
nurse and i make about 120 000 a year
and i'm going to go be a school nurse to
have my kids full schedule and my salary
is going to drop down to about
80 000 a year
and my husband makes about 120 as well
and we just sold our car so we just got
rid of 33 000
and we have about 35 000 in credit card
debt and about 180 in our mortgage
so i just wanted to know i'm just having
a hard time with the whole salary
reduction and how much is enough for a
family
that's a great question and you guys are
in california and so i know this looks
different for people in high cost of
living areas but you don't get a pass on
the math and the truth is
it really doesn't matter i mean there's
people who make forty thousand dollars
who live very comfortably there's people
who live in million dollar houses who
feel like they don't have enough and so
what's gonna make you feel like you have
enough is when you have margin and right
now you've got a pile of debt here in
thirty five thousand dollars of credit
card debt that's making you feel like
you don't have enough and so can you
live on 200 000 income which is what
you'll go to in california comfortably
yeah you can but not when you have a
pile of debt breathing down your net
emeraldo what's the 35 000. i know it's
credit card debt but like what what are
you guys charging on oh
it was just we did um furniture
and just like odds and ends that have
piled up over the years yeah so over the
years you've been paying on this debt
for a long time
probably about two years just kind of
the last year and a half we've just kind
of been living life and
um
yeah buying stuff going on vacation and
now that i'm able to i finished my bsn
so i was able to apply for a school
nurse position and now that i'm actually
going to take it i'm like whoa well i
know i'm going to take a picture but now
i'm like oh is this the right move right
now brett
yeah well me here's the deal you're
still going to be making around 200 if
you're making 80 he's making 120
you guys are still making an incredible
income
and so
y'all's issue is gonna have to be hey
i'm gonna have to set some boundaries
and actually get serious about this
because you guys have kind of just been
floating around having fun going on
vacation buying stuff and just not
really thinking because you've had the
money to cover your mistakes and
suddenly when you don't have the money
to cover your mistakes anymore and
you're down forty thousand dollars a
year
yeah it's gonna you're gonna feel it
exactly what you're calling right you're
feeling that intensity and and as well
that's the intensity that you're going
to have to clean this up i mean people
they do it all the time and and if i
were you guys i mean your life is going
to look
drastically different for the next nine
months of your life like i would buckle
down and do nothing i would i would sell
some stuff you guys bought on those
credit cards that you're not using
anymore i would not go out to eat i
would not go on vacation i would do
nothing and i would get rid of this
because if you can take this intensity
and actually get serious about it this
35 000 will go away you guys have the
income to be able to do it you're going
to be able to really knock this out even
if you go and take the nursing job which
is not mad if you do that i think that
if that's what you're wanting to do
that's great because you guys still are
going to have a great income to pay this
off but you got to get serious about it
and you guys have not been serious about
this and man when you pay this off like
george said it's going to put you in a
different spot it is going to it is
going to bring the freedom that you're
wanting right now to be able to switch
jobs and not feel distressed
okay yeah we sold our cards on monday
which that took off 33 000 and we have
two other cards that are paid for so
we're good with that and my husband's
like i'm so proud of you you actually
gave up a nice luxury car to drive your
paid off car i was like well i want to
do this i want to be able to be home and
spend more time with the kids and you
know my salary eventually will go up to
a hundred thousand in about three years
each year i'll get a pay raise and of
course he will as well
so yeah i guess it's just a drop down
right now that i'm like oh we're gonna
get to get adjusted a little bit and
well here's the thing esmerelda you
called asking how much money do you need
to live comfortably and right now i
don't want you to be comfortable i want
you to be uncomfortable for a short
season so that you can live your best
life later on completely debt free
because clearly this comfortable living
doing whatever you guys wanted to do
it's not a great life because you're
sitting here with a little bit of
anxiety about is money enough and what
about these bills that we're paying and
maybe some buyers remorse some regret
some shame and i don't want any of that
in your life and you guys have a
fantastic income like rachel said buckle
down get rid of this thing in six months
and uh clean up get an emergency fund in
place do you guys have any savings right
now
we do we have about um like 20 000 or so
okay well if you're following the baby
steps throw it at the debt you've got 1
000 starter and 19 is gonna get thrown
on that 35 of credit card debt and all
of a sudden you're gonna go oh my gosh
we can see the light at the end of the
tunnel i would write a big check tonight
esmeralda i really would because i i
y'all need a shock you need like george
said you kind of just been floating
around like you you need something to
kind of shock the system and man when
you do that and you soccer and you said
okay we're gonna just throw this get rid
of all this other debt pay down the
credit card it's gonna make you get into
gear to pay off the rest because you're
gonna want that emergency fund back
because you want to get comfortable
again which i don't blame you uh but you
need a little you need a little shock to
the system yeah i'm here for it you guys
got it you guys got it esmerell you
could do this i'm not worried about it
but you're gonna have to get some
self-discipline in place and get
uncomfortable so that you can be
comfortable later on that's true
financial peace this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined today by
rachel cruz you are listening to the
ramsay show give us a call triple eight
eight two five five two two five we'll
talk about your life and your money pat
joins us in sioux falls pat welcome to
the ramsay show
hello
yeah hey i just started a little
business in llc and i went to the bank
to get a
an account business account going and
they recommended a credit card that they
did
yeah they did
and uh you know back in my mind i knew
what they would say but um
i'm calling to see if i was right about
what they would say no credit cards it
doesn't matter if it's business or
personal or nothing that
that that sounds about right to me uh
did you end up doing it
i did but oh boy um
but i can cancel it so i haven't even
got it in the mail yet like i said i was
going i was wavering and i called my
wife and she said yeah i get it you know
and then
and i still went back and forth and then
i said well i tried to call you guys
like yesterday too but hey hey don't put
this on us pat all right
i got voicemail you can sign up for the
credit card pat i got voicemail so i
decided to go into debt
uh well pat tell me this what was your
reasoning going you know what i'm just
gonna go ahead and do that probably gave
you some good some good excuses well
i'll tell you i'll tell you what it was
it was um
my wife was thought the 1.5 would be
cash back would be
ah
cash back you talk to successful
business owners and they're like man the
1.5 is what did it
so i'm going to be a multiple you know a
bunch of this it's just a little small
business and i just you know it happened
so fast you're filling out all these
forms from this llc and everything else
and
you know then this and that and so yeah
i can get rid of it i just wanted to
check with dave before i didn't
whenever it comes to these decisions pat
i like to go who benefits from this
decision
and in this case the bank benefits from
this decision that's why they're pushing
the credit card is because they're not
going to make a whole bunch of money
from you taking out a business debit
card
they're hoping you rack up some some
debt on this thing and pay a whole bunch
of interest over the course of your life
running this business
so i'd like to win i appreciate you guys
taking my call absolutely thanks pat
thanks for cutting it up as soon as as
soon as that card comes in cut it up and
maybe go to a different bank uh just to
just to stick it to them and get a
business debit card that's what bank
will do the same thing george well go to
a credit union i just don't want to do
business with a bank that sold me a
credit card that's all i'm saying that's
what they all do though right well yeah
i mean they're banks this is this is
what they do they're out to make money
that's what they're doing but uh that's
what we do here at ramsey right so we're
a big company millions upon millions of
dollars and we only use debit cards sure
believe it or not yep yep even the real
estate here
is paid for
we move at the speed of cash is what we
say around here um
and what it does though i mean from on a
business perspective is it makes you
make different business decisions when
you are using cash when you're using
debt there's a level of oh we try to
test it if it doesn't i don't know you
know you're not as emotionally kind of
freaked out but when it's your cash
you're like i'm gonna
make sure this thing that we're
investing in
is gonna give me some roi you just you
have a deeper emotional investment when
it's your own money and then on the flip
side on the consumer side with the
points i mean this is when we hear all
the time george so people have credit
cards you know whether it's oh it's a
just-in-case thing
or i do it for the airline miles and the
points
and
what i've you know one thing i want
people to realize is that you know when
because people do pay off their credit
cards every month right there are people
out there they're paying off and they're
quote unquote benefiting
and they're they are getting the cash
back all that but you understand you're
getting all of these points
because other majority of people the
average american is carrying 16 000
credit card balance so people because
they are mismanaging their money and the
banks are making tons of money off that
you now quote unquote get to reap the
benefits of a system that's screwing
people
and they're putting people in bad
positions so i'm like i don't even want
to play the game i don't even want the
points because because you're you're not
you're doing it dirty money a little bit
is what it feels like because i'm like
because there's some
you know single mom out there is trying
to make her bills
and she's using the credit card to help
her in that because it's the only thing
she knows and i get a i get
a free 70 southwest fly i'm like no no i
will pay for my own southwest flight
thank you like i don't
there's a moral argument to be made that
we really don't talk a bunch here ramsay
solutions we stick to the financial part
but there is a part where it's just it's
a corrupt industry and it's hurting
people and you have to decide do i want
to be a part of an industry that does
this to people i don't want to play the
game and yeah 1.5
is not going to change your life it's a
few hundred bucks back and i tell i tell
people give yourself some cash back
that's what you can do when you live a
debt-free life and you have the margin
in your budget and if i want to go on
vacation i don't have to hope that i
have the points at the end of the year
we just budget for it and go on vacation
that's right that's simple yes so we've
got an episode all about this on
my podcast the fine print and it's
called the true cost of credit card
rewards so if this is you and you're out
there and you're going well what if i
pay it off every month and what if and
what if and what if and you're wrong
just go listen to the episode uh we
talked to an ex capital one employee
elena who really dished she spilled the
tea all right on on the credit card
industry 10 000 social experiments they
run you're just a you're just a mouse in
their maze wow when you get to the
cheese you think but i'm winning i got
cheese and then you zoom out and you go
no you're just a mouse in a lab
being socially experimented on wow so go
check out that episode uh you can go to
fineprintpodcast.com or just search for
the fine print wherever you listen to
podcasts all right let's take a call
here we've got lauren in las vegas
nevada lauren welcome to the ramsay show
i'll get him next time
thank you kelly for putting me through
um real quick um my husband and i were
on baby step six yay for the program
congrats of you guys
thank you um we just moved into our home
here in vegas and we did it the ramsay
way um we're just trying to decide um
how much to save for home improvements
versus paying down our mortgage
after everything we have about a surplus
i mean on average from two to five
thousand that
you know i either put towards paying off
the mortgage but then i thought maybe i
should pause doing that and
save for improvements
i don't know well i i don't think it's
in either or here i mean how urgent are
these improvements are these nice to
haves or is like the roof gonna collapse
no these are definitely nice to have
um we plan to be in this house for i
mean as much as you can plan right uh
ten years yeah at least
you know we're in a neighborhood we
picked this neighborhood for our kids we
want to grow up and you know have our
kids grow up with friends in the
neighborhood so that's where we're at
it's awesome uh how much is left on the
mortgage
um
a good number um i mean
uh
yeah you can't shock us just
throw it out there okay one million yeah
okay
we're still here and you said you did at
the ramsey way which makes me think you
guys can afford you put 20 down or 10 10
to 20 down and the mortgage payments no
more
yep i i just sound funny to say out loud
what's your household income i'm curious
yeah it's um
i mean the
350 base and then
add-ons yeah great it's awesome you guys
are doing great
way to go thank you yeah my husband
works very hard and we're a good team so
well don't be ashamed
yeah so i think um
so lauren with the money you guys are
putting extra you said you're having you
have two to five thousand i guess a
month so you're saying extra on average
yeah yeah so yeah when i say that
because some it's not we don't have
overage and then other days or other
months we have like 5k it's just the
timing of things totally so well at this
point here's what i would do and george
you obviously i don't hear your thoughts
but um you guys look at so the mortgage
you got about a million left
and i would do i would do a 10-year plan
that you're gonna be in this house for
10 years and say okay
when do we want this mortgage paid off
like when would it feel great and do
some math to see okay what's realistic
if we because again you're on baby step
six so we say this is the time you get
to kind of take your foot off the gas
enjoy life a little do some house
improvements you can do some of this but
i would still have a time frame a goal
just for you and your husband to know
hey we would love to have our house paid
off in x amount of time and that could
be in five years that could be in seven
years but kind of aggressive because we
really want you to have that house paid
off um but that feels good but for you
to still have margin in your budget to
live life because i still want you to
say hey okay so that's our goal is to
get it paid off here so then how much
extra do we have per month to play with
how much how many vacations we want to
take a year um
you know do we do a one improvement on
the house maybe one every year and we
cash flow it so you you can still live
your life lauren so it is going to be
it's not an either or
uh it is a both but it's a it's a
decision
yeah we don't want to be wasteful
because i've got to tell you i was what
your dad called a princess before
i know you're
you're not being wasteful at all you're
doing great just just allocate to both
and start saving up in a sinking fund
and maybe you start paying off the house
once those improvements are done
hardcore waiting good job though laura
you're doing great that puts this hour
in the books this is the ransomware
family member that needs a daily dose of
ramsey advice in their life let them
know about the ramsey call of the day
podcast it's a quick hit of advice about
life and money in under 10 minutes check
out the ramsey call of the day podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsey show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm george campbell host of the
fine print and entree leadership podcast
joined today by rachel cruz host of the
rachel cruze show and best-selling
author and we are excited to take your
calls this hour about life and money so
give us a call triple eight eight two
five
five two two five michaela kicks us off
in kansas city missouri mikayla welcome
to the ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call we're glad
to take it how can we help
so i'm a small business owner
married we have two younger kiddos and
um just
gosh with everything that's going on in
washington
um they officially passed the
um
whatever you want to call it the
buildback whatever uh bill
today and knowing the implications that
that is going to have
on me as a small business owner um
especially
in my industry um i'm just kind of
curious we um are so close i guess you
could say to paying off our home
and
knowing that this bill fundamentally
fiscally changes um the system of
finance in america i'm told my finite
mind um comprehends that it changes the
stock market as we know it and there's
potential for it to crash and not come
back and this is not like whatever
conspiracy of it whatever this is just
all the information that people throw at
you right and so i'm i'm kind of
wondering do i should we pull out what
we have in the stock market to just
finish paying off our home not knowing
whether or not you know the kgb is going
to cut i mean the irs is going to come
and you know then audit and close down
all small businesses or
let's do a quick exercise together we're
going to take a deep breath we're going
to do three in and three out hold for
three seconds in yeah
right
and then out for three there we go okay
it's not past the senate
we got our news source it is it is not
past the senate okay
okay did you hear that okay okay so it's
not
it has not passed yet
i am a bill on capitol hill did you you
know that you know listen rachel's all
about some singing today so you might
get some of that because
i might be rapping about how laws are in
place i mean jesus could come tomorrow
but i still i'm still going to pay my
bills up until that moment and so i
understand that you have valid fears
especially as a small businessman it's
just fair p.s i don't i don't want to
invalidate i get it yes
but on the side of the market's going to
crash and i don't need to upheave my
life i don't think we're going to be
able to time it if it happens
so if i'm you i'm going to keep living
my life here now i do want to know about
your investments when you say
pull out money out of the stock market
what do you have invested currently
um well we kind of i feel like have a
little bit of everything kind of
everywhere so we've got
um and i think it's if i understand
right it's like 60 40 in um conservative
um like stocks and bonds versus like
more aggressive are you invested in
mutual funds or single stocks
um some of both
some of both um we do have um an ira
um a roth iras i am um you know
obviously self-employed my husband um
does not have a um
yeah i mean he just started his new job
and so we don't have like a 401k there
um we do have i have a small business
emergency
fund that's separate just in like an
ally account
um and then we thought our other
emergency three to six months for our
personal home
so it's just kind of everywhere um how
much do you have so let's separate
retirement from non-retirement so we're
not going to touch retirement let's just
take that off the table we're not going
to pull any money out of our retirement
accounts how much money do you have
outside of that in just a general
brokerage account
uh
all of them together probably about
40 or so
and then because i am a sole proprietor
llc technically everything in my small
business account is mine i could pull it
out i have about 90 in there
and how much do you have left on the
mortgage
about
80
okay
it's the home's worth about i could we
could sell it right now our
neighborhood's pretty hot um we could
sell it for about 340 probably right now
okay so we've got 80 left on the
mortgage you have 40 000 just sitting
out there in general mutual funds and
stocks that are non-retirement correct
right okay so that portion i would say
yes let's pull that out not out of fear
but just because the best use of that
money right now is paying off this
mortgage versus being in the stock
market especially the ones that are in
single stocks that are super volatile
and risky
okay so that cuts you down to 40. now
the business money uh do you need that
money for anything is it reserves for
your business what are you doing with
that
um well
full disclosure so some of it comes from
i'm an enneagram one so like perfection
is the only option right
um and your way's the right way
enneagram ones
also that also that thank you for being
here you've encountered enneagram rachel
i know you all right yes i see you
michaela i see you
um
part of it so
i was in business with a family member
there was some trauma there um the
business or the family member that i was
in business with decided um after me
finally getting it for myself and saying
no more
um didn't understand why she wouldn't be
paid for not working decided that she
would just take all of our money out of
the account close the account i had no
idea um and
it then like then it took like three
years to sort of rebuild because i knew
i wasn't going anywhere i loved what i
did um i knew that's where i was
supposed to be
um so a lot of yeah a lot i guess trauma
there and so i just
i
this sounds horrible but like i hoard it
there i think because sure out of the
fear yeah but what if that happened yes
100 percent yeah
it doesn't get it
it's not right
i have my i have my emergency fund uh
for my business but i don't know i mean
i'm self-employed you never know
especially with taxes being raised like
you never know really um in an industry
like i'm in you never really know
exactly how much you're going to owe in
taxes because
your profit fluctuates so much like 2020
we operated at 11
that we operated at in 2019 because i'm
in the wedding industry
so do you have a tax professional that
you work with right now
oh yeah oh yeah okay well work with them
and get facts on paper because as john
doloni says facts are your friends and
let's not live in just fear and paranoia
and i understand that you have
legitimate fears but what i want you to
do is just turn off the news slow down
your life and do the next right thing
that you need to do every day go work in
your business and don't live by the
headlines because truthfully they're
overblown and it's never as crazy as
they say it is on both sides i'm not
this is not a political party i do love
conspiracies but rachel does kayla so i
can jump on the train and go there
that's ramsay after dark it's where
rachel shares her conspiracy theories
but uh michaela i really appreciate the
call and uh way to go in your business
and just take a deep breath
well that money feeling so great put it
toward the mortgage like you said and
start work and chip that mortgage away
yep and you're doing great you'll have
some awesome financial peace you'll
sleep a lot easier with no mortgage but
no more paranoia no more fear no more
headlines just take a break for safety's
sake this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over 70 a month by switching to
pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
this is a big week here at ramsey you
know most people know dave ramsey is the
rich guy on the radio and that he is he
made his first million in his 20s and he
did it the wrong way and went bankrupt
many of you know that story and that's
when he set out to learn god's ways of
managing money and created the ramsay
baby steps and by following these steps
dave became a millionaire again and this
time he did it the right way with zero
debt he spent the next three decades
guiding millions through the same plan
he followed and today the evidence is
undeniable if you follow the baby steps
you will become a millionaire and get to
live and give like no one else
and he covers all of this in his new
book called baby steps millionaires
that's available for pre-order now
you'll learn how ordinary people build
extraordinary wealth and how you can do
it too it's not out of reach he walks
you through how to invest build wealth
and bust through the barriers preventing
you from becoming a millionaire so for
those who are ready it's game on you can
baby step your way to becoming a
millionaire you can pre-order your copy
today at ramsaysolutions.com
and we sweeten the deal we've got over a
hundred dollars worth of bonus items
when you pre-order including the baby
steps millionaire's audiobook and e-book
and dave actually reads the audiobook
himself which is that's going to be a
good time you also get the legacy
journey audiobook and ebook and the baby
steps millionaires live stream
along with ramsey smart tax you can file
for free using that including a ramsay
plus 30 day free trial there's so much
in there rachel i'm super pumped for
this book and the cover is just
beautiful i must say say that same thing
such a beautiful it's dave on the farm
at sunrise i know he's out in the field
very excited in the wild yes with a no
teeth smile and this has been
the smirk and uh this is dave's first
book in a long time i know it's an
awesome a long time and so i'm pumped
for it there's some awesome stories in
here you're gonna learn how dave
personally invests his money and uh i'm
i'm baby stepping my way to be a
millionaire i'm excited to pay off my
house maybe by the end of the year close
you and whitney fingers crossed by the
end of the year rachel we're paying off
the house
by the end of the year like
yes oh my gosh george i know i know are
you gonna do a debt-free scream i want
to do you think it'd be weird no
okay that's a new poll should george do
a dead freezer i'm here for maybe with
confetti we also don't really have a say
it's going to be kelly
so we have to decide if kelly wants me
to do that free spring oh kelly decides
when he pays off his house at the end of
the year
yes kelly said yes america it's gonna
happen that's like a and that's a big
deal and i'm just i'm so proud of you
and whitney the way you guys went about
that whole thing because i remember you
guys building yeah you because it was it
was a newer build yep and you were able
to pick up the finishes and you guys
were being so smart about the upgrade i
mean all of it and and you did it so
well thank you i'm excited that means a
lot it's awesome yeah it's been just
over two years
so it can be done i'm not that special
i'm not like a financial genius we just
followed the baby steps and we created
margin by paying off our debt and we've
been been investing diligently and those
of you know my story my wife works here
at ramsey solutions so not a huge leap
to get her on board
she's all in on this stuff and so we're
super excited and i just want everyone
to know that the stuff in this book is
not theory
it's real stories real everyday people
not you know athletes and celebrities
they're everyday people they're teachers
they're engineers who just diligently
saved and followed the steps and did it
so i'm super pumped for this book make
sure you go grab your copy at
ramseysolutions.com open phones this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two is the number to call jessie joins
us in springfield jesse welcome to the
ramsey show
hey guys thanks for having me on
absolutely how can we help
well
my wife and i are on baby step number
two um just kind of just getting the
ball rolling right now
however we got a call my uncle passed
away and my sister and i are his heirs
wow i'm sorry to hear that
oh thank you guys i appreciate it it was
it was a pretty sudden but
you know he's in a better place than we
are i guess yeah
um
so
we know it's going to be a substantial
amount of money it should be somewhere
between 100 and 150 um
for my sister and and for myself
but we know it was not in the will but
we do know his wishes that he wanted to
take care of my kids and my sister's
kids colleges
my wife and i are on the fence of
whether or not we use this money to get
out of all of our consumer debt
everything but the home
and fund the college ourselves or
whether or not we just leave this money
invested
and to use it for their college
how many kids do you have and what are
the ages
i have two that are six and three okay
so we've got a long ways away for
college and how much debt do you have
yes consumer debt other than the
mortgage
consumer debt if you count school loans
it's about 120.
okay and when you said 100 250 is that
each so you're saying two to three
hundred total
um correct okay
so if we're saying two to three hundred
total here and you have 120 in debt that
means you can clean up the debt wait no
he's going to get 150 the sister will
get 150.
oh the sister yes yes i think it's split
in half yep so 100 to 150
so with this money you will maybe be
able to clean up all of your consumer
debt
and that's it correct yes
and then you're saying can we just then
fund our kids college and will that be
enough to kind of be a blessing to the
legacy that he left you
right that's exactly the question yeah
this may be a little technical i don't
know this is kind of what went in my
head because
i don't know if you feel this jessie
because there's two ways you can look at
it one it's like yeah you use the money
strictly for hit what he wanted is what
you know of the kid's college
um or you used to pay off debt and like
you're saying go through the baby steps
by the time your kids are are 18 you're
gonna have plenty of money to send them
to college um
so there's like kind of the or i like
that kind of the both options so what
you could do if you
if it makes you sleep better at night
you could open up you know a 529 or an
esa and start out
with a little bit to put in there so
it's like you start the college fund
with his money
and then use the remaining to pay off
your debt and then as you and your wife
get to baby step five then you guys fund
the rest of it but almost it's kind of
like he
his money kind of kicked off a little
bit of the funds you know just special
because if you put some money in there
now at their age you've got uh 12 and 15
years for that money to grow and the esa
has a has a limit so i think it's close
to about 2 000. yeah so that's 4 000 of
150 000 just to get them started
jesse just so there's kind of a okay i
don't know a little bit of a symbolism
there yeah just to say hey there's
there's some of that and then using the
rest yep to pay off your debt because
again his legacy for them to go to
college will be fulfilled because of you
guys
either way it's because of that legacy
he left that's right that to me
it's still there yeah but i like what
rachel's saying about starting that esa
for them right now and you could front
load a 529 and get that money rolling in
your favor and the the limits on that
are going to be a lot different and so
you can put a lot more in there but make
sure you've got a good option for your
area i would connect with a smart
investor pro in your area you can jump
onto ramseysolutions.com they're going
to really help guide this decision and
figure out what is the best vehicle to
make sure that your kids colleges are
paid for and that this money grows in
the best way yeah but but jesse hear me
say though i would i would still take
majority of it and pay off the debt
though like i mean i'm just saying take
a little bit of it just to kind of start
it out of memory for him
but i would still use majority of it i
would i would i would put it towards the
debt um to set you and your wife up to
really fund those colleges sooner than
later maybe set a goal you guys propose
now that you guys propose that option
what makes sense to me is if i were to
pay off my
all we have is two vehicles and a school
loan so if we paid off the two vehicles
and put the rest into a 503
then
the the snowball would already be so big
we would be through the school loan in
no time
okay what's your household income
uh about 110
okay
so either way we're gonna get rid of
this debt fast um but i do like the idea
of setting aside some of the money uh
for that the college for the kids and
letting that grow for the next 12 to 15
years and maybe set a goal and say hey
we're gonna we're gonna make sure that
we have a hundred thousand saved by the
time both of them are 18. and you can
work with the smartvestor pro and start
to go okay with a rate of return of this
how much would we need to put in to get
there and that'll make you feel better
knowing that this money is going to grow
and make sure that they're taken care of
and that legacy was was used wisely
so way to go man absolutely thank you
guys that sounds like great advice i
appreciate you absolutely jesse thanks
so much
wow
that's really cool it's sad to hear
about the loss but when you hear about
them leaving that legacy where the kids
can go to college debt-free i know it
just makes you go that's the kind of
legacy i want to leave i know it's
awesome yep absolutely beautiful stuff
all right this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined today by
rachel cruz you are listening to the
ramsay show open phones this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
ramsay to get the best deal
today's question comes from joshua in
indiana
my wife and i are debt free including
our house becoming debt-free has been
important to us because of the spiritual
component of not owing anyone anything
my problem is that i don't know many
people that are truly debt-free the
people i know who are successful with
money have taken out heloc's on paid for
homes to invest the money in the stock
market or real estate my financial
advisor thinks that i'm silly to not
leverage some form of debt with interest
rates being so low
my wife and i are considering doing a
home addition that would cost around 100
to 125 000
my advisor says that i should take out a
hundred thousand dollar equity from take
out a hundred thousand dollars of equity
from my house invest it and use the
earned interest to pay for the remodel
this makes sense and sounds very
appealing however i'm fighting not to
wanting to get back into debt i hear
dave talk about your study of
millionaires and how people that got out
of debt never go back into debt again
unfortunately i just don't see that done
around me what am i missing
a lot to unpack here rachel man where to
begin george so first of all joshua way
to go baby step seven yeah paid off the
house i hope you stay there joshua
you're starting to move backwards so
well here's the thing he's asking the
people i know who are successful have
taken out heloc's on paid off homes to
invest the money in the stock market and
it really comes down to what is your
definition of success
is it people who leverage debt up to
their eyeballs and one day the market
crashes and their life is screwed and
they have to file for bankruptcy or is
it i don't owe anyone anything and you
said in the beginning that becoming
debt-free has been important because of
the spiritual component of not owing
anyone anything
so here's what's hard about all of this
especially when you get into this
conversation about
investing and real estate and i can
invest my mortgage payment make more on
the interest and you know i mean like
there's all these taxes
interest rates are so low you're stupid
to pay it off yeah about the mortgages
or even things like this like the heloc
but here's what people you touched on
this george but it's just true here's
what people don't take into
consideration
is the amount of risk that you're
putting on yourself that you don't have
right now joshua you have no risk if
something happens right now you haven't
paid for it you're fine like you don't
bills
and suddenly when you start kind of
messing around and again the math could
work you could we could sit here and do
a whole math lesson
and it could come out on paper
right like it could come out
but what you don't factor in is risk you
don't factor in life you don't factor in
you know that that something could you
know happen to your i mean this terrible
say but right that something could
happen to your wife and and she wants to
stay home then with the kids not work
and now you have this bill and you took
this out and now you have to have the
income because you took on this debt i
mean like it just snowballs into this
insanity and you don't have to step into
that
and so
there's a level of that freedom that i
think is way more successful than
messing around with the numbers and
trying to kind of get rich quick is what
it feels like i want to i want an easy
way to build wealth well this is easy um
instead of actually working and saving
i'm paying for something i'm gonna
finagle the market and finagle my assets
that i have here to try to make some you
know it's like this math game
you know what get out of the game just
save them and pay for stuff it can be
that simple and that clean yeah and it's
amazing that they've done the baby steps
yeah and they're still at this place
mentally of was this the right choice i
mean do you want a mortgage again joshua
buyer your financial advisor 100 stupid
get rid of them i highly doubt they're
smartvestor pro because they don't have
the heart of a teacher they're telling
you to go back into debt and invest it
and use the earned interest to pay for
this remodel that's dumb you guys have
the money how much is he getting huh
that's the question who's going to win
in this scenario joshua if i'm
you've got to stop looking to the
culture
to figure out what success looks like
financially because they don't have a
clue man walk down the streets look at
all the cars with loans on them the
homes that are over leveraged and you
tell me what success is when the bank
can't come take your house when you
can't make a payment yeah and so you
have all the income in the world you
don't know anyone anything and therefore
you can pay for that home edition of a
hundred thousand dollars you can save up
and pay cash for it cash flow that thing
without needing to take equity from the
house and do all kinds of stupid don't
go backwards that's right keep going
forward thanks thanks for asking joshua
good good question there steve joins us
from wichita steve welcome to the ramsay
show
thank you for taking my call sure how
can we help
yeah well i'm trying to make a decision
here i am
i've been a uh
straight commissioned salesperson for
through the years i'm an independent
contractor i've been very well in it um
last year was a bit of a struggle
because of covid
it did affect my business
and um
but i still had a pretty average year
income wise
last uh so then this year uh thinking
that everything would get quite a bit
better it actually hasn't
my business is down about 40 this year
um
so my struggle here is um wondering if i
should use some cash to pay off my house
and a truck loan
um
being on straight commission i'm just
not
really comfortable pulling the trigger
on that
how much money do you have in in cash
and savings
well right now i've got um
close to
right around 100 000 in cash uh liquid
cash
um i've got about 70 cash on hand i've
got a ten thousand dollar emergency fund
and
about a year ago i started another
independent uh
sales job it only doesn't sales but an
independent business
that i make about 20 000 a year on that
also i'm trying to keep that separately
so what's your average yearly income
obviously this year was different
yeah with um
with the straight commission i'm usually
around 80 to 110 000. okay
and how much do you have in that in
total
uh the only debt i have is uh 41 000 on
a house and about 13 on a truck we have
no other debt okay um i am
getting ready to do a home improvement
that i will use about 15 000 in cash to
do that
um what i'm seeing here on paper is you
could pay off the truck loan
pay off your house
and do these home renovations
all with the money you have and still
have some left over and still have your
emergency fund is that right
that's true
i'm just being on being on straight
commission for 30 years you know it's
just you want to have a bigger emergency
fund in case the sales don't come in
yeah yeah you know and it's just like
said
it is something i could do
um i'm just hesitant to pull the trigger
on how about this steve if you don't
have a mortgage your expenses are going
to go down right so there's less to
worry about there
and so then i would plan out what does
six months of
expenses look like if i didn't have a
mortgage and that's going to give you
some peace here way more than having the
car loan and the mortgage riding on your
shoulders
yeah because steve you'll have about 30
i mean from what i jotted down if i got
the numbers right you mean you'll still
have about 30 000 left over after you do
all of that
um which is a pretty solid emergency
fund you can always bump that up if it
still does that doesn't make you
comfortable and
i know the income went down you said
what kind of business are you in
what are you selling promotional
products and corporate apparel okay
and so with uh kovad last year there
were no events everybody started
canceling events
and
i thought it would take up quite a bit
this year and
it just hasn't come up to my
expectations as far as my business goes
now i don't know what next year is going
to do you know right i don't know yeah
but um this year's down that's why i'm
hesitating this year to
you know go ahead and chunk that money
out
and steve do you have anything in
retirement do you have anything in
retirement
yeah my wife uh just retired so she's
you know she's got her social security
and we do have investments that we
haven't tapped into yet so she's pulling
social security only okay um i'm 64 so
i'm not ready to retire and i probably
won't retire till i reach full
retirement age okay
that's great well i want you to still be
thinking about that
before the house has paid off if you
want to throw some extra at the
retirement just because you're getting
close to that age yep yeah but man the
true financial security true financial
piece is gonna come from not owing
anyone anything get rid of that mortgage
get rid of the truck loan you'll still
have plenty of money left over well done
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
our scripture of the day comes from
proverbs 13 12.
hope deferred makes the heart sick but a
longing fulfilled is a tree of life
dale carnegie said most of the important
things in the world have been
accomplished by people who have kept on
trying when there seemed to be no hope
at all
open phones this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
you know rachel i was just with uh my
pal dr john deloney yeah and he gave me
these uh these little cards and he just
released these and they're really fun
they're called questions for humans by
dr john deloney and it's literally a
pack of cards a deck of cards that have
questions and there's three different
kinds you get the parents and kids
edition the couple's edition and the
friends edition and he gave me the
parents and kids edition which i don't
have kids and he gave us the couple's
edition and we thought you know what
let's try our hand at this and george
was like at the break okay let's go
through a couple and pick some out and i
said no george let's just randomly pick
out of the deck this is delony we have
full
um permission because george and i are
not a couple that we get to put at least
two back if they're like inappropriate a
couple questions because it's doctor
johnson to be clear uh this is fun the
reason he did this he's always telling
people to unplug to connect with real
people
and this is a way to actually have real
conversation instead of staring at each
other awkwardly okay
here's my first one um if you could try
three different careers what would they
be oh that's a fun one am i answering
for myself or does this like
you answer i answered and i'll answer
okay three different careers what would
they be
number one i would be a political
correspondent
that's good for a news network yep
absolutely follow campaigns rounds
number two
i would be a singer
oh nice arena style like tv
okay oh yeah like i would but i i almost
would go for the younger generation like
the whole miley cyrus hannah montana
thing you know she she you're the crowd
she dropped hannah montana i'm like you
could have taken that brand hannah
montana could have gone to college
hannah montana could have gotten married
sorry like she could have made bank on
that brand but she decided to go
different directions clearly but i would
have done that i would have done like
the teeny bopper yep
yeah all right and then my third um um
oh my gosh maybe like a like like um
like on a caribbean island type
situation that's not is that how is that
a career i'm not sure you just want to
be on a caribbean island i'm just going
to be a
president
well there you go folks she wants to be
a political correspondent a pop star or
just live on the caribbean okay for me
i'm gonna go uh late night show host
okay uh a rockefeller center would be
fun yeah that's a one career uh mailman
really there's something about such a
simple you're just delivering people the
most i love it and you just walk around
everyone loves the mailman
yeah you get to wear the shorts with the
high socks it's kind of like dorky and
old school mr rogers had a mailman it
just feels cool i love that george you
could do that and then lastly weatherman
oh meteorologist i grew up watching
meteorologists and on the news and i
just thought that looks like fun you
know a storm trace chaser would be fun
you're much more adventurous i just want
to be in front of the green screen
pointing
rachel wants to be in the middle of the
storm oh my george the year this
this is what america needs
uh all right
if you if i took you to a tattoo parlor
right now and you had to get a tattoo
what would it be
that's a fun one
i would get
like kids initials winston like i would
do like a like a a family oriented like
a yeah something um i don't know if i'd
want to visit i don't know maybe like on
my like my ring oh that would be nice
yeah like all the initials on your right
do that yeah yeah sweet something like
that that's what would you do george um
i was gonna say my wife's name but i
feel like getting an actual little like
camel symbol like a little you know
cause my last name's camel with a k it
only feels right to get an actual camel
um maybe with whitney's initials in it
that would make it sweet and not as
weird
but i'm not a tattoo guy i'm not you
know no one would take me seriously if i
had a full sleeve no they're like nah we
don't buy it i'm like well crap it's on
my body forever now
yeah you know we got a lot of tatted
people here at ramsey and they look
really cool one of our engineers in the
booth
james childs no tattoos
okay uh i
well uh folks if you want to check these
out you can go to ramseysolutions.com
uh they've got a deck of cards for
couples for parents and kids um
and for
friends yes
so there we go check it out questions
for humans by dr john dolone this is
great to bring home for the holidays yes
because it's sometimes hard to connect
with with family and you're trying to
catch up and this kind of relieves the
tension and you really learn a lot and
you'll have a lot of laughs and uh it's
a great mailman george with the camel
tattoo yeah i always was obsessed with
ups guys all the brown i had a thing for
the color brown yeah just total i don't
know what what they always bring
happiness you know
all right let's take a call uh before
james takes us off the air scott joins
us in minneapolis minnesota scott
welcome to the ramsay show
hi thanks for having me hey how can we
help today
uh so i'm a 29 year old um currently
paying an additional 2 400 on my the
principle of my mortgage each month way
to go i should have it yeah thanks um i
should have it paid off by december of
2023 if i keep on
being able to pay the same amount
um i don't really enjoy my job right now
and i was thinking about going back to
college and getting into maybe a field
of engineering or finance
just kind of wondering an opinion should
i wait until i pay off my house before
going back to college or should i call
it paying off my mortgage on hold so
that i don't have to go into student
loan debt and i can instead use that
money for my student loans or yeah
that's a great it's a great question
well here's the thing uh i don't think
you need to you don't have to be in a
rush to pay off the house i don't want
you to be miserable for years and just
to say well i paid off my house now i
can pay cash for school can you
pay save up and pay cash for school as
soon as possible and then attack the
house after that
i mean i'm sure that i could and
especially if i get into a higher paying
job after college then probably even be
easier to pay off the loan and that's
sort of what i'm wearing right now
what's your income
um right now i make 46 000 a year and my
wife makes about 20 000 so combined
close to about 70. and you have 2 400
extra to put on the mortgage every month
after all said and done
yep absolutely because i've been
following the baby steps got all out of
debt and we don't have many extra
expenses we just kind of live minimalist
that's awesome so great um scott do you
know what you want to do um like i
almost would want you to have like a
career out there that you're working
towards
um before you go get a degree because
there are
situations that you don't even need a
degree depending on where you work where
you could change jobs and not
feel like you have to go and invest in a
degree now some some career paths
obviously you have to have higher
education um for so that would make
total sense but i just wonder if there's
something out there that you could do
that still gets that fulfillment you can
change
career paths without having to get a
degree
sure what i'm looking at out of my
degree right now would be environmental
engineering would be kind of the goal or
possibly a personal financial person
would be
kind of my
idealistic world but yeah
i've looked into other things like
certificates and things i could get as
well and
none of them have really stuck to me as
much as those career paths sure sure
which is yeah totally fine well um yeah
i think once you kind of figure out and
narrow down hey this is the path i want
to do whether it is
doing engineering or personal finance
but once you kind of figure that out
then going for a degree that you're
going to need in the dream job after
you know if you if you hold on scott
kelly can pick up and give you uh ken
coleman's new book paycheck to purpose
because he walks people through a plan
kind of where you're at of kind of
figuring out okay what do i want to do
what are the steps that i need to really
change
and and oh yeah and she said the clear
assessment too is what will give you
that because um all of these tools are
really going to i think help
give you more insight and more of a game
plan um to have something that you're
shooting for so hopefully those will
help and then make sure that education
matches the goals and figure out what is
the right college choice that i can
afford in cash and cash flow and uh that
house will pay itself off i mean you
guys are so gazelle intense i'm not
worried about that house getting paid
off soon i want to make sure that you're
living in your purpose doing something
that you really love to do and that
you're getting paid well yeah do it way
to go man great job scott all right that
puts this hour of the ramsey show in the
books i want to thank my co-host rachel
cruz good times today rachel i want to
thank our friends in the booth there
james childs our producer kelly daniel
our associate producer and phone
screener and you america it's been a fun
one we'll be back with you before you
know it until then
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously this is the ramsay show
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell alexa google assistant or siri to
play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
you